Who would win: The Hard to Destroy Reptile,
or 9.15 million kilograms of bananas?
This is SCP-682 VS SCP-3521
When SCP-682 was cross-tested with SCP-3521
- A little yellow pill that makes bananas
manifest in the stomach of those who eat them
- the Foundation hoped to answer that question.
682 was tricked into eating the pill by hiding
it inside the body of a dead cow, which was
then fed to the monster.
As time passed, an absurd number of bananas
began to manifest in and around SCP-682, filling
its containment chamber and then the entire
facility.
However, just when it seemed 682 was crushed
under all that potassium, it began eating
the bananas faster than they could be produced.
And because bananas are each slightly naturally
radioactive, eating that many gave SCP-682
the ability to fire a powerful radiation beam
out of its mouth until 3521’s effects wore
off.
The craziest part?
This all occurred within a ten-minute period.
Guess you could say things went a little bananas
in there.